sieht aber nicht aus wie csi nähe liegen
das interview heute mit ihnen ist wow
klassen frau noch mal ab nochmal auch
noch mal
ohne sieht halt schöner das ist alles
nicht sicherheits grundform sowie
vielleicht gleich für den opening shot
die brille so ein bisschen so so ganz
denker mäßig so im unternehmen das ist
aber nicht meine arbeit noch so eine
denkpause einlegen wenn sie was eine
denkerpose und danach proben nehmen und
ganz wissenshungrige durchgucken und
schüttelt dabei
ja das ist ja das ist es das ist super
sie sichert dass der kolben in den
trockenen schrank stehen soll das macht
man normalerweise nicht das sagen sie
doch einfach mal an ganz frei von ihrer
therapie zu erzählen ja also ich arbeite
in dem bereich drug delivery das ist
relevant in der krebsforschung zum
beispiel da ist ja durchaus medikamente
gibt die für bestimmte krebsarten
wirksam sind als jetzt direkt schon sehr
kompliziert viel zu unruhig werden sie
dann mit dieser therapie den nobelpreis
gewinnen
den nobelpreis kartoffel pro tag der
nobelpreis wird ja normalerweise
verlieren an lebenswerke auch von
wissenschaftlern die sind jetzt eben
also würde ich hier auch gar nicht nach
ihm gemeint ich sagen sie doch am besten
einfach mal
wir werden mit dieser neuen therapie den
krebs in fünf jahren besiegt haben kann
ich nicht sagen dass das ist einfach
nicht akkurat man kann das auch
normalerweise physio ergo ist wenn die
formel die formel ja die formel matze
ich glaube das haben wir dann also ich
hab nichts mehr
kleinster realistisch
aber wir müssen auch gleich weiter wir
haben noch den tod feststellen
wir machen einfach ganz schnell ein
anderes thema durch wie ist es dann mit
glyphosat wir direkt küste meist kochen
ist ein engagement wurde hier meinung zu
gender studies klappt einfach mal
aufbauen rauslassen ist was ist alle
wollen wir das überhaupt
bitcoins ich bin chemikerin alle elf
minuten wird wissenschaft von den medien
falsch dargestellt
ich weiß nicht ob die statistik so
stimmt hey ich heiße mai ich bin
chemikerin und youtube in und wenn ihr
wissenschaft haben wollt die
unterhaltsam und korrekt ist dann müsst
ihr mit app abonnieren denn hier sind
die wissenschaftler nicht nur vor
sondern auch hinter der kamera
diejenigen die mir bei instagram folgen
business wahrscheinlich schon ich bin
demnächst wirklich wollte im fernsehen
freunde und zwar es ist so cool
boxencrew auch immer selbst geschaut
habe also quarks als es jetzt noch es
ist jedenfalls der perfekte beweis dafür
dass wissenschaft und fernsehen doch
funktioniert falls es also neulich sät
kann ich es spätestens jetzt wärmstens
empfehlen wenn ihr nichts verpassen
wollt mir auf instagram und zusammen mit
einem eil app abo seite dennoch bestens
ausgerüstet wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag freunde der sonne bis dahin
bleibt sicher